mais d'abord direction calais sur fond
de bras de fer diplomatique entre paris
et londres l'urgence de ces dernières 48
heures c'était de trouver des solutions
d'hébergement provisoire pour les
migrants jonathan du prix m l'état
l'avait promis proposer systématiquement
un hébergement temporaire aux migrants
déloger de leur campement de fortune à
calais c'est désormais chose faite un
sas de 300 places de mise à l'abri vient
d'être créé à cet effet cette solution
d'urgence émane du médiateur
gouvernementale chargée de négocier avec
plusieurs associatif toujours en grève
de la faim ils réclament depuis trois
semaines l'arrêt des expulsions lors de
la trêve hivernale ils protestent contre
le traitement réservé aux migrants à
calais retrouve dans une situation qui
devient de plus en plus difficile une
oppression envers les personnes exilées
qui est quotidienne voire jeudi aux
pressions mais voir harcèlement des
forces de l'ordre
une oppression aussi envers les
associatifs les militants l'égalisation
leader si les militants dénoncent la
gestion de l'état sur ce dossier épineux
le gouvernement quant à lui renvoie la
balle à londres début octobre lors d'un
déplacement dans le pas de calais gérald
darmanin avait sommé les anglais de
payer à la france les 62,7 millions
d'euros promis afin de renforcer les
contrôles frontaliers depuis l'hexagone
nous appelons les anglais à tenir leurs
promesses de financement puisque nous
tenons la frontière pour eux ici et
maintenant et puis évidemment de réduire
au crunch leur attractivité pour les
immigrés qui arrivent en grande bretagne
peu après ces déclarations les anglais
se sont engagés à verser la somme alors
que la france et le royaume-uni
s'écharpent depuis des années sur la
question des migrants dans la manche les
tentatives de traversée s'intensifie
selon les derniers chiffres des
autorités françaises plus de quinze
mille migrants ont tenté de rejoindre
l'angleterre depuis le 1er janvier
et pour notre débats d'actu sur les
migrants de calais je vous présente mes
invités karima delli bonjour bienvenue
vous êtes eurodéputée europe ecologie
les verts moutier a calé ce week-end
pour soutenir les grévistes de la faim
qui dénoncent les conditions de vie des
migrants didier leschi bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directeur général de
l'office français de l'intégration et de
l'immigration vous avez été nommé
médiateur par le ministre de l'intérieur
il y a
huit jours dans ce dossier à l'amm says
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
correspondant du times à paris jacques a
également guillaume daret éditorialistes
son article sur france tv on remercie
donc aux français nous prêter guillaume
daret pour pour quelle que soit c'est
sympa de vous avoir footmercato voilà
c'est un petit mercato temporaire on va
on va démarrer tout de suite sur ses
skis l'actualité c'est assez 300 places
d'hébergement provisoires qui ont été
que vous avez annoncé didier leschi
elles sont elles sont déjà disponibles
ou vont-elles être être proposé en or
comme je l ai indiqué à la fois au
collectif des associations et aux
grévistes de la faim les propositions de
la médiation vont être mises en oeuvre
il s'agit d'un sas de 300 classes et qui
doit permettre d'héberger une ceux qui
sont dans les campements informels et
qui ont besoin d'un hébergement et le
dispositif ça s'est permis organisé dès
le lendemain des départs vers des places
d'hébergement pérennes puisque l'enjeu
n'est pas de stabiliser les personnes
sur cale est mais bien de répartir la
charge de l'accueil dans l'ensemble de
la région donc ça sera sur toute la
région des hauts de france en soute sur
toute la région des hauts de france ouai
c'est un progrès pour vous karima delli
absolument pas puisque on parle de 300
personnes hébergées en trêve hivernale
alors qu'on compte environ 1500
personnes tuées je suis content d'être
sur votre plateau parce que je voudrais
témoigner ma solidarité aux grévistes le
père philippe des maistre anaïs et
ludovic vous savez on est dans un moment
terrible c'est le déni de réalité la
situation à calais aujourd'hui elle est
pas nouvelle mais aujourd'hui on attend
tenta un visibiliser les exilés et
pourtant ils subissent une politique est
indigne des tentes ont été lacérées
détente qui on comprend comme ça vous
êtes tous les deux jours il ya une
expulsion à calais voyez tous les deux
jours des associations qui ont du mal à
travailler parce que justement leur dit
vous n'avez pas circuler ce n'est plus
le moment de travailler et je vais vous
dire moi j'ai un peu mal au coeur mal au
coeur parce que
je suis allé plusieurs fois à calais
comme à grande synthe ce sont des femmes
des hommes et des enfants qui vit dans
des conditions mais vraiment indigne
quand je dis indigne ces îles qui sont
d'ailleurs de plus alors la première
chose je pense que quand on est
responsable politique
il faut arrêter de toujours parce que
qu'elle est devenue aujourd'hui une
ville forteresse on n'a jamais eu autant
de barbelés c'est incroyable tous les
endroits même les espaces verts à calais
aujourd'hui sont bien des clôtures de
partout voyez la première chose que je
crois qu'il faut faire c'est de mettre
toutes les associations autour de la
table vite les associations humanitaires
et ensuite d'arrêter d'avoir cédé ni
je vous raconte qu'elle est un sujet
complexe mais quel est le reflet un peu
du chaos du monde et la difficulté en
partie des rapports avec avec
l'angleterre est une sorte de mirage
mais je rappelle quand même qu'à calais
il ya une centaine d'emplois associative
qui sont plus en charge par l'état
justement pour l'accueil des migrants à
calais il y à des douches et un système
de navettes qui permet aux migrants
d'accès des douches l'état
distribue des repas tous les jours et il
s'agit pas simplement de 300 places
puisque le fisher à peu près cent dix
mille places d'hébergement à travers la
france il s'agit de permettre à ceux qui
arrivent et qui sont dans ces contenants
informel d'avoir une première étape
avant l'orientation vers l'ensemble des
hébergements et bien évidemment l'idée
c'est que chaque personne qui accepte un
hébergement puissent y accéder puisque
un des débats que nous avons et c'est ça
qui est compliqué c'est une partie des
migrants qui sont là refusent ne
souhaite pas aller dans les hébergements
donc il s'agit de les convaincre que
c'est pour ça aussi qu'il va y avoir des
maraudes qui vont s'intensifier pour
dire aux personnes vous pouvez en france
déposé une demande d'asile vous pouvez
accéder à un hébergement et je crois que
ne pas réfléchir en fonction de la
complexité ses frères preuve de
faciliter ce problème il est ancien
quels que soient les gouvernements je
dirais puisque moi je suis un modeste
fonctionnaire eh bien on a essayé de le
prendre avec le maximum d'humanité c'est
pas toujours simple mais je crois qu'il
ne faut pas caricaturer la situation
alors on reviendra sur notamment sur la
question des effectivement des effets
personnels des tenté d'actionner les
policiers en la matière parce que vous
êtes en train de faire évoluer les
choses je voudrais vous entendre adam
said sur la situation parce qu'il faut
bien comprendre ce qui se passe il ya eu
dans la nuit de
de lundi à mardi près de 300 personnes
qui ont été sauvées emmerder sauvetage
alors qu'il était sur des embarcations
de fortune pourquoi les millions ne
passe plus par le par le tunnel pourquoi
ils prennent autant de risques pour leur
vie en ce moment ah ben je pense qu'on
en a qui passent par dessus une
intrusion enfin si je vais également à
calais je fais un règlement et le
reportage à calais bon ils essaient
toujours de passer par le tunnel il
arrive plus ou moins de ceux qui payent
les passeurs yves ceux qui paient pas
les passeurs et par où il ya des
sécurités beaucoup pignon et dispositifs
de sécurité sur le tunnel qui a été
remonté ces derniers années avec
nombreuses techniques de détection de
chaleur détection de co2 les chiens et
setra qui fait que c'est effectivement
très compliqué ah et puis
si vous parlez aux associations il y a
toujours eu très très très peu de
tentatives de traversée en bateau depuis
des années il ya deux ans pour une
raison que qui est difficile à expliquer
mais je crois est essentiellement parce
que quelques-uns sont arrivés en
angleterre ils ont appelé en france pose
et on est arrivé fort et c'est donc
dépassé par bateau saint-marceau donc
donc ce phénomène bateau à augmenter et
à augmenter lentement et
élimineront son du compte que c'est
finalement beaucoup plus facile de
passer en bateau par le tunnel mais
beaucoup plus dangereux
si beaucoup plus dangereux quand vous
parlez aux migrants par rapport au
danger ceux qui sont venus de la coupe
d'afrique ceux qui sont venus de
l'afghanistan qu'ils avaient traversé
les autres ici
vaincus ont traversé la libye la
méditerranée bondit ce qu'un danger mais
c'est finalement pas énorme par rapport
aux risques on a déjà concouru en
arriver là j'aimerais qu'on parle de la
pression policière effectivement il ya
c'est peut-être le point qui vous
choquer le le plus c'est ce que vous
avez cités karima delli le fait que les
policiers régulièrement pour récupérer
les effets personnels des migrants c'est
ça il ya ça c'est c'est terrible au fait
que tous les deux jours les expulsions
non lieu on prend les affaires de ces
exilés on entasse des sacs à dos et des
tentes des bâches voir des chaussures
dans des bennes ils vont les récupérer
que quelques heures après et tout le
temps avec la peur au ventre vous en
rendez compte de harcèlement physique
morale de ces exilés moi je trouve que
c'est là où on un pont je vous en veux
pas vous vous faites votre travail de
médiateur mais j'ai un problème de fond
sur la réponse je crois pas qu'une
politique sécuritaire fonctionne on l'a
vu depuis maintenant de très nombreuses
années tout cet argent mis dans un
armada de policiers que ça ne fonctionne
pas - je préférerais qu'on met
l'ensemble de cet argent dans des
véritable politique d'accueil et c'est
là où jean rage parce que non moi je
suis des hauts de france font je peux
vous dire qu'ils aient des mers et
notamment je pense à mon ami damien
carême à grande synthe qui avait fait ex
quelque chose d'extraordinaire vous
parlez des passeurs tout à l'heure c'est
très intéressant pourquoi on en arrive
aux pacers parce que la politique
sécuritaire est tel que maintenant le
trafic des passerelles est telle que je
rappelle que le trafic des passeurs
c'est quand même le troisième trafic
mondial après la drogue et les armes
wade parce qu'ils ont trouvé quelque
chose qui fait que comme on sait pas
accueillir il s'engouffre dans la loire
c'est quoi ces poils alternative aux ben
moi je crois que
l'alternative là tout de suite c'est de
dire pas d'expulsion sans relogement
vous avez tout à l'heure
je voudrais aller sur le terrain avec
natacha bouchart qu'est la mer de la vie
mr lr2 qu'elle est quand vous entendez
karima delli
l'instant dire que finalement la
solution sécuritaire elle c'était un
échec depuis depuis des années qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que vous en pensez natacha
bouchart parce que ce que j'en pense
c'est que nous on vient pas juste faire
un passage à calais on y vit jour nuit
week ends jours fériés depuis maintenant
20 ans et je pense que la politique
sécuritaire et quand même exemplaire et
donc j'estime que les forces de l'ordre
font dans la plus grande dignité leur
travail
la problématique est complètement
différente c'est que on est face à des
migrants qui ne veulent pas rester sur
le territoire français qui me demande
rien à la france et qui trouble l'ordre
public en permanence et donc moi ga à
gérer et vient le trouble public et les
traumatismes de de ma population et nous
sommes six mois avant les
présidentielles alors tout le monde va
passer avec son petit chemin pour rester
une heure ou deux venir voir ce qui se
passe ne rien y comprendre donner son
opinion de son salon de son bureau
parisien où l'européen et puis ne pas
comprendre que si on n'a pas de conseil
interministériel
qui nous permettent de réunir le
ministre de l'intérieur celui de
l'immigration
celui des affaires étrangères celui
également et bien des finances eh bien
on va pas s'en sortir et pilleurs on
arrive à un dispositif aujourd'hui où le
break si tu es là qu'elle est une huile
frontières il est temps de remettre les
choses sur la table
des centres d'accueil pour les migrants
je pense que et je n'ai de leçon à
recevoir de personne
j'en ai fait beaucoup et j'ai tout
essayé
entre les douches les airs de repas
les airs de douche qui ont même brûlé
les plans grand froid les les centres
pour remise à l'abri des femmes et des
enfants rien n'a fonctionné donc
moi ce que je dis c'est que
effectivement j'entends parler de sas
mais de sas oui mais pas à calais et le
sac à l'essai à veut dire une aspiration
et ça veut dire l'aspiration ça veut
dire 300 ça veut dire six ans ça y est
remis ça veut dire 1500 ça veut dire dix
mille ça veut dire 2016 et je pense que
tous les traumatismes qu'on a vécu eh
bien on a pas en vous envie de je dirais
les les airs mettre en en traumatismes
et que le sens en fait de de ce
dispositif et et bâle prix il n'a besoin
de beaucoup de hauteur donné à la
consultation vous vous réclamez un
comité interministériel on l'a bien
compris vous dites que grosso modo la
solution du ca ce que le médiateur que
didier leschi a à proposer pas et est
pas suffisante hameau de réponse à
dessus puis ensuite on va on va élargir
avec vous guillaume que jal à la
position de madame bouchard a raison il
faut tout faire pour éviter la
reconstitution de ce que les migrants
appelé eux mêmes la jungle voilà et donc
il faut éviter un point de fixation
autour duquel
ddd regroupement informel se feront et
donc c'est pour ça qu'on est les
policiers avaient pour consigne d'aller
tirer les tentes et c'est pour ça que
tous les deux nous sommes dans un
dispositif juridique qui est supervisé
par le procureur de la république
s'appelle la flagrance et qui oblige du
point de vue du droit à évacuer les
personnes dans le délai de fragrances
qui théoriquement est autour de 48
heures ne pas le faire c'est rentrer
dans un autre dispositif juridique
c'est-à-dire saisir le tribunal sur une
longue durée et à ce moment là on aura
la reconstitution de la langue de calais
parce qu'on ne pourra pas évacuer les
coups de poing donc il faut continuer à
le faire voilà les dispositifs
d'évacuation il les améliorer du point
de vue des effets personnels des
migrants c'est indéniable et c'est ce
que j'ai proposé mais ce qu'il ne faut
pas absolument faire et vous prenez
l'exemple de daniel picara mais je pense
que c'est un exemple qui peut-être mal
venu parce que le problème de la
structure solide qui a été fait à à
grande synthe à un moment donné elle n'a
plus été contrôlés ni par la mairie ni
par les forces de police elle était
contrôlée que par les passeurs il faut
éviter que mes et met en place des jeux
ne servent que des passeurs et du reste
est prof c'est que le maire suivante ya
succédèrent messieurs damien carême eh
bien il a arrêté ce type de dispositif
justement parce que personne n'arrivait
à les contrôler il faut faire dans cette
affaire ni preuve d'angélisme ni preuve
de dureté il faut trouver un juste
équilibre et je crois que tout l'enjeu
de la médiation c'est trouver le juste
équilibre sans démagogie aucune norme et
ouais je vais revenir sur ça la
politique de damien carême était
exemplaire son successeur n'a pas voulu
rééditer le tellement cette police est
là où c'était au moins des passeurs là
on a deux c'est plus compliqué que ça ce
qui est sûr aujourd'hui c'est que j'ai
pas de leçon à recevoir de madame
bouchard qui me dit je ne suis pas de
passage à calais je suis né dans le nord
et je connais très bien quelle est la
preuve la deuxième chose c'est que je
crois qu' on est dans une politique du
vrai cynisme et je parlais de cynisme
aujourd'hui pourquoi je dis ça parce que
lorsqu'on parle d'hommes d'enfants etc
on n'a pas le temps de se dire bon
quelle technique on va mettre en place
on parle de l'humain et ces gens ont des
droits qu'on doit respecter d'accord les
droits humains doivent être respectées
lorsque vous me dites aujourd'hui on va
enfin
enfin faire attention à l'heure à faire
attention aux tentes mais on est en 2011
vous savez 1500 personnes c'est le cas
en 2020
2021 mais 1500 personnes c'est pas toute
la misère du monde or qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire concrètement la première
chose qu'il faut faire c'est pas c'est
pas juste faire justement encore plus
sécuritaire etc je crois que la première
chose c'est de mettre autour de la table
les autorités britanniques et les
autorités
aman française là c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose ce qui n'a pas
encore été fait puisque lors du vrai
excité je peux vous le dire je t'aime
table de négociations ce sujet n'a pas
été abordé ensuite on doit prendre le
sujet notamment des réfugiés des exilés
comme un vrai sujet notamment pas dans
le déni parce qu'on a peur on a peur
justement lorsque j'entends certains
dire attention pas faux pas du tout les
installer parce que vous savez quoi ça à
faire un appel d'air
l'imaginaire de l'appel d'air ça vient
de l'extrême droite depuis des années
tous les spécialistes disent une chose
il n'y a pas d'appel d'air il n'y a pas
d'appel d'air
tous ceux qui disent le contraire qui me
le prouve intellectuellement et
scientifiquement ça n'existe pas donc ce
qu'il faut faire c'est d'une part
prendre un dialogue avec les autorités
anglet 1 anglaise et britanniques un
vrai dialogue avec l'ensemble des
associations et je le redis très bien
monsieur le médiateur
vous avez vous dis une chose pas
d'expulsion sans relogement son
hébergement à ma millions 10 ans pas
d'expulsion sans enfin ils tablent
relogement mais le premier jour de la
trêve hivernale qu'est ce que vous avez
fait mais la première chose que vous
avez fait c'est d'expulser des gens et
notamment des exilés donc je pense qu'il
faut aussi arrêter les doubles discours
vous voyez on peut pas dire être dans
l'angélisme comme ça on dit on fait des
choses et ses terrains et en même temps
concrètement ça ne marche pas la
deuxième chose c'est que je voudrais
vous dire alors on doit être et je
termine là je voudrais que chacun doit
on doit se réveiller on vient des
pompiers
franches pour agir 7 et sur les jours
c'est natacha bouchart
j'entends bien j'entends bien ce dilemme
karima delli mais je je je ne peux pas
aller dans son sens non seulement parce
que on a vécu grande synthe et et on
sait qu' il y a eu effectivement une
prise en main des passeurs et des
activistes associatif et c'est pour cela
que ce campement a dû être démantelé
vous dire aussi que très clairement ça
n'est pas en gardant et bien ces
migrants dans la boue dans des lieux qui
sont inacceptables humainement pour
qu'on va les aider aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe c'est que on n'est pas capable de
prendre des bus est de mettre ces
personnes à l'abri à l'abri c'est à dire
il faut la fermeté il faut l'humanité
mais la mise à l'abri il faut pas
mélanger tous les migrants les migrants
qui sont à calais madame ne veulent pas
rester à calais les migrants qui sont à
quai les veulent passer en angleterre
donc on n'est pas du tout dans le même
débat et vous vous êtes vous vivez
peut-être dans l'est ou de france mais
vous ne vivez pas à calais et moi ce que
je dis c'est que il est important qu'on
ait aujourd'hui ce comité
interministériel et que le fait d'ouvrir
un lieu pour 300 migrants n'est pas une
bonne chose parce que on va se retrouver
avec onze mille milles grand que ses
enfants on
a des
arguments book pardon de vous
interrompre
vous charmer est-ce que je voudrais
qu'on avance un peu d'envié bas sur le
pot sur la partie je vous donnerai la
part ou tout à l'heure c'est promis je
voudrais qu'on reprenne un peu et qu'on
ouvre un peu le débat sur le contexte
franco britannique parce que c'est paris
a effectivement il ya le brick city à
les relations entre boris johnson et le
président français guillaume daret cetc
je pense qu'eux avaient vécu janvier
vous songé je parle sous le contrô le de
mon collègue britannique mais c'est vrai
qu' on ne peut pas
parler de ce sujet sans parler de boris
johnson et comme souvent il utilise la
politique internationale pour faire de
la politique nationale parce qu'il ya
actuellement un projet de loi de lutte
contre l'immigration clandestine qui est
travaillé en commission au parlement
britannique qui vise à réduire
drastiquement le droit des personnes qui
arrivent clandestinement en matière de
prestations sociales en matière
également de droit à l'accueil de
regroupement familial et donc il ya des
consignes qu'on était passés aussi au
ministère en charge de la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale de dire on se
montrent particulièrement ferme et donc
effectivement c'est pas un moment où ce
sera particulièrement facile pour les
français de discuter avec boris johnson
de rediscuter peut-être les fameux
accords du touquet qui établissent
effectivement la frontière entre la
france et la grande bretagne du côté
français de 2003 et en plus les
et en plus là les relations personnelles
on l'a vu ces derniers jours
effectivement entre boris johnson et
emmanuel macron sur la question de la
pêche ne sont pas des plus favorables
donc sur ce dossier là ça s'annonce
particulièrement compliquée pour les
autorités françaises savent où est
l'éthique et pourquoi oui parce que la
tête et tout cas dans le toit à la
france et à la volonté de faire les
contrôles dans l'autre paie donc c'est
ça oui mais pour l'instant c'est au
point leur au stade 2
les policiers français sont assez minces
donc c'est pas un très gros risque de
freiner son sens laissé par un traité
qui établit l'affronter en france et
d'être traités qui marche dans les deux
sens effectivement les migrants sont en
point sur le contexte politique
britannique est ce que le fait qu'ils
c'est ce changement de deux textes de
lois qui se prépare ça peut expliquer
aussi un affluent de ce dernier moment
pour passer et de bénéficier encore en
hausse tandis que les réseaux ne passe à
utiliser cet argument mais ils ont
utilisé tous les arguments imaginables
vous savez ils ont dit il faut passer
avant le procès et il fallait passer
avant 2016 je savais très bien qu'ils
font des publicités en ligne et hors
ligne pour l'agora 12 allée en même
temps vous allez trouver
un travail et un logement même ils vont
en réalité publie ses réseaux à ça
qu'ils vont tout le temps en montagne il
fait beau tous les jours donc c'est donc
certainement qu'ils utilisent cet
argument non je vois pas mais je crois
pas du tout que c'est c'est quelque
chose qu'ils font de vente 1 dont le
fait qu'il ya une augmentation dans ce
moment sans doute que ces jours ci on
voit une augmentation du nombre de
traversées parce que l'hiver approche
parce que ça c'est le temps joue
beaucoup celui bateau effectivement mais
effectivement boris johnson veut durcir
sa politique migratoire ça fait partie
mais oui bien sûr de la logique de son
arrivée au pouvoir oui bien sûr oui
absolument à
le gouvernement britannique ça fait ça
fait trop longtemps que je couvre ce
problème à calais depuis mes premiers
reportages à calais c'était quand j
avais d amener
les venelles bouches on s'en souvient
c'était dans les années 90 donc cesser
c'est quelque chose que c'est pas
nouveau du tout venant et à c'est une
politique assez cocasse et consistant du
plan britannique de vouloir empêcher les
migrants arrivés clandestinement en
montagne effectivement impressionnants a
promis un an durcissement de sa
politique notamment parce que ce qui
était caché avant je crois un cd vraie
raison ce qui était caché avant parce
que ça passe une année dans les camions
est maintenant visible à la une de
toutes les télévisions donc ça les mises
à son médiatique politique publique est
considérable a et qui veut qu'on vous
avez très bien écrire en jeu c'est avec
une loi qui augmente de 6 mois à 4 ans
de prison la peine maximale pour entrée
illégale en bretagne mais vous voyez
cédé face à emmanuel macron par exemple
sur cette question
qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'est ce que
vous a précédé par rapport à emmanuel
macron montagne dit
deux choses en fait
premièrement à
on
s'est mis en difficulté avec le
président à mesure qu'on ait pu partir
du traité de dublin et c'est trés devenu
très compliqué de deux s'étaient déjà
difficile inde expulser les migrants
vers la première fois que bp sur en
europe ce qu'il accorde une trentaine
dublin maintenant c'est devenu
impossible donc nous voulons
traiter avec la france a pour pouvoir
renvoyer un certain nombre d'amis vont
arriver tranquillement en montagne en
france donc il ya un mage nage de
manoeuvre je crois pour la france autour
de cette question à la question et
savoir et si j'ai bien compris les
autorités français voudraient je pense
qu'en même temps la grand-bretagne
accepte de prendre un certain nombre de
mes compétences mineurs ou peut-être
dans un cadre d'un effondrement
familiales qui sont déjà calées
est-ce qu'on va arriver à trouver un
accord autour de ces questions ça va
être un bras de fer
on va avoir beaucoup de bruit beaucoup
d' insulte à mais au final notre intérêt
est de pouvoir
retrouver un accord avec la france 3
avec l'union européenne prouvant vois un
certain nombre de mégots l'intérêt de la
france et de pouvoir faire en sorte au
moins revenir aux mineurs puissent
retrouver des familles en même temps
donc peut-être et à la dendre
possibilité tout verna corps et on voit
la complexité quand même deux de la
situation je me retourne vers natacha
bouchart vous vous demandez à un comité
interministériel en fait si s'il n'y a
pas les anglais à la table ça ne sert
pas à grand-chose énergie non il faut il
faut il faut les associer vous comprenez
parce que tout ce beau monde là qui est
en train de discuter eux ils en ont rien
à faire puisque c'est pas eux qui en
subissent les conséquences sur le
terrain
donc moi ce que je dis aujourd'hui c'est
que il faut imposer à ce que le maire de
calais passe partie des négociations et
boris johnson il faut lui c'est un bras
de fer et les britanniques ne savent
fonctionner que comme ça et si les
migrants continuent à passer en
angleterre c'est parce que le
gouvernement britannique n'a pas le
courage de revoir le le dispositif en
fête d'accueil qui là parce que les
migrants ont toujours les les revenus
quand ils arrivent sur le territoire ils
ont toujours le travail au noir ils ont
toujours leurs avantages on coule ça
reste un eldorado donc je moi je suis
désolé aujourd'hui moi ce que je dis
c'est que si on est pas on va pas vers
ce bras de fer on va pas y arriver tout
simplement donc il faut que
on est des personnes qui vivent des
choses tous les jours qui viennent
effectivement durcir le ton avec boris
johnson - boris johnson ne fait pas peur
quand il commença à faire ces grandes
envolées lyriques et à dire ah bah on va
prendre les bateaux les femmes les
enfants qui arrivent qui ont traversé la
manche on va les renvoyer et puis tant
pis pour eux histoire sur le retour du
du chemin c'est quand même scandaleux
donc aujourd'hui on voit bien que on
n'est pas au niveau où on doit l'être et
le niveau il est la sortie en fait du
royaume uni et il faut revoir ses
accords bilatéraux entre la france et
l'angleterre vous sur la partie donc des
accords du touquet alors moi je vous
demande et je reprends la main vous
demander plus de fermeté c'est
intéressant guillaume d'arrêt parce que
évidemment c'est pas nouveau là aussi
vous disiez ça fait 30 ans que ça dure
mais dans la dent dans l'histoire
politique française c'est aussi un thème
l'immigration voilà qui est récurrent
qui est un marqueur politique fort et
qui là en pleine campagne présidentielle
joue ce rôle aussi oui une façon est
particulièrement d'ailleurs chez les
républicains parce qu'ils sont persuadés
tomax c'est l'un des points de faiblesse
des manuels macro mais donc ils veulent
montrer leur différence avec lui sur ce
sur ce sujet là et aussi parce qu'il se
retrouve sous la pression d'eric zemmour
qui est extrêmement présent sur cette
thématique alors tous vous avez vu
quasiment propose un référendum sur
cette question de l'immigration michel
barnier lui demande un moratoire et
xavier bertrand s'est montré extrêmement
ferme chez nos confrères de bfm tv en
particulier sur cette question des
migrants à calais extrêmement ferme
tapant très fort sur emmanuel macron
écoutez le
vous savez qu'à calais des migrants
exploités par les passeurs mettre des
barricades sur la rocade avec tous les
dangers que ça représente c'est
l'attaqué de la diligence il fait quoi
le gouvernement et le troisième sujet ce
sont les anglais les anglais ça commence
à bien faire cela fait maintenant cinq
ans depuis que je suis élu la tête de la
région que je dis très clairement que
s'ils ne veulent pas faire le travail
qui est le leur on le rend leur
frontière et ont dénoncé accord du
touquet cinq ans que je demande cinq ans
que le président de la république quatre
ans et demi qu'il fait la sourde oreille
quelle attitude feu adopté emmanuel
macron alors c'est délicat parce qu'à la
fois il veut pas perdre ses électeurs de
gauche qui lui sont restés fidèles et
qui demandent je cite plus d'humanité
qui avait pas aimé par exemple
rappelez-vous thomas après ça à la chute
de kaboul et la déclaration du chef de
l'état quand il avait évoqué des jeux
site flux migratoires irréguliers le
risque en tout cas de flux migratoires
irréguliers et en même temps il veut pas
laisser emmanuel macron le terrain de la
fermeté à la droite il a donc choisi
d'aller sur ce terrain de l'immigration
de la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine et de donner aussi des
signes y compris sur l'immigration
légale puisque rappelez vous il ya
quelques semaines il a décidé de réduire
de moitié les visas accordés notamment
aux algériens et aux marocains est ce
que c'est vraiment la thématique qui
intéresse le plus rêver les français
alors c'est vrai que c'est sûrement une
des thématiques qui fait le plus de
bruit en tout cas médiatiquement et
politiquement mais c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant de voir si c'est la priorité
des français est-ce qu'on voit quand on
regarde à peu près toutes les études
d'opinion récente c'est que oui c'est
une préoccupation des français à la
proche de l'élection présidentielle mais
attention ce n'est pas la seule
préoccupation et ce n'est pas la
première préoccupation
une étude d'opinion réalisée par
l'institut de sondage gis lab il ya une
dizaine de jours qui montrent que ce
n'est même que la troisième
préoccupation des français loin derrière
le pouvoir d'achat et la sécurité alors
ça veut pas dire thomas que ça
n'intéresse pas les français mais ça
veut dire que la campagne présidentielle
elle ne pourra pas se faire que sur
cette thématique là et que donc les
candidats qui considèrent qu'ils
pourront emporter nos suffrages vos
suffrages en parlant seulement
d'immigration eh bien ces candidats là
ce tronçon est ce que c'est vrai la
pression didier leschi ce contexte quand
on est un haut fonctionnaire quand on
est nommé médiateur par le ministre de
l'intérieur et qu'on se sait comme ça
scruté par
nos journalistes les chaînes d'info et
écoutez moi je suis un fonctionnaire je
suis un technicien voilà
j'ai commencé mon travail autour de
calais quand bernard cazeneuve et
ministre de l'intérieur et ils étaient
confrontés aux mêmes critiques que
j'entends aujourd'hui et il essayait d'y
répondre voilà je pense que il ya une
complexité et les débats autour de
l'immigration comme j'ai écrit dans un
livre ça dérange un peu tout le temps
les esprits il faut garder son calme
voilà il ya un chaos du monde avait
gardé des flux migratoires
il faut essayer de les gérer sans
angélisme mais sans et sans refuser de
faire preuve d'humanité c'est ce qu'on
essaye de faire depuis des années ça ne
se réglera pas du jour au lendemain on
se dit mon servent nos rapports avec
l'angleterre ils sont compliqués je
dirais depuis la révolution française
enfin va
les régler comme ça d'un coup de
cuillère à pot en même temps on
n'imagine pas dit du côté anglais ni le
côté français d'installer des ferries
pour que les gens traversent était alors
qu'ils sont en vie et on emmène on
n'imagine pas le porte avions charles de
gaulle stationnées dans la manche pour
obliger les anglais à ouvrir la
frontière dont il faut rester
raisonnable rester raisonnable c'est je
crois deux choses d'un côté
prendre les choses de manière
suffisamment humaine sans angeli ses
terres qu'il ya pas un droit à
stationner où on veut quand on veut la
trêve hivernale c'est d'avoir un toit et
c'est ce que propose l'état à travers
l'idée d'un hébergement systématique
voilà d'un côté pour faire ça et et de
l'autre côté il faut absolument empêcher
la reconstitution de ce qu'on a connu à
la 1 mondial qui était la langue de cas
là je vous propose une image d'archivés
pour pour rebondir sur ce que je venais
dit on et le 2 mars 2016 et c'est
effectivement ce que le terme officiel
c'est la lande de calais mais le le
surnom c'était la jungle c'est
démantèlement à coup de bulldozer
images spectaculaires qui était aussi
voulu on peut faire un peu l'analyse de
communication par le prémice de l'époque
manuel valls il sera définitivement
démanteler ce lieu détruit en octobre
2016 est ce que dans les consignes
didier leschi que vous avez c'est de ne
pas laisser un tel dans mes yeux c'est
ce se reconstituer c'est vraiment
l'obsession c'est absolument l'objet de
ma médiation c'est d'essayer de faire
comprendre à ce petit groupe
d'associations parce que là qu'elles
aient toutes les associations ne sont
pas sur la même longueur d'onde il ya
même une partie d'associations qui
refuse d'être de se réunir avec les
autres parce qu'il considère qu' ils
sont des opérateurs de l'état je pense à
france terre d'asile et donc du coup il
serait illégitime mais je rappelle en ce
qui concerne l'évacuation de de la
langue de calais qui a été fait en mars
2016 du coup la question migratoire n'a
pas été au coeur de l'élection
présidentielle et j'ajoute que il y
avait eu des craintes exprimées par un
certain nombre d'élus qu'on allait
exporter décalé à travers la france ce
n'est pas ce qui a été fait on a fait la
démonstration un que dès lors que les
personnes acceptait de déposer une
demande d'asile ils pouvaient rentrer
dans un parcours positif d'intégration
en france et si c'est absolument ce que
ce qui s'est passé est donc le but là
actuellement c'est d'inciter les
personnes dans un moment de pause qui
peut être deux à quatre heure ou un peu
plus de réfléchir sur le parcours
migratoire de ne pas accepter ce mirage
revendu par par les passeurs qui est le
mirage anglais qui est souvent un mirage
d'exploitation en angleterre il faut
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont
d'exploitation en angleterre et il leur
faire comprendre que de rester aux mains
des passeurs c'est resté dans la pire
des situations et qu'il y a un droit
légitime de l'état français considéré
qu' on n'a pas le droit de stationner
dans la boue karima delli si yannick
jadot est élu il fait quoi de différent
il fait un geste à la angela merkel en
2015 qui avait ouvert le territoire de
l'allemagne aux réfugiés syriens à
millions de réfugiés qui était venu
s'installer en allemagne dont emmanuel
cas dont emmanuel macron avait dit
emmanuel mais madame merkel est la seule
en europe à avoir sauvé l'honneur sauver
l'honneur de l'europe à cela quand on
essaie aujourd'hui comprend un certain
mépris dans la république il faut
balayer devant sa porte voici ce que
vous proposez moi ce que je dis
d'ailleurs entre les dents à l'époque
oui mais il avait il l'a toujours dit
quelles que soient ses défauts
je vous aime a coupé dans vos compères
vous me coupait pas d'enjeu c'est une
chose mais on personnes qui sont
rentrées mais aujourd'hui à calais ce
qu'on voit ce sont des migrants qui
justement été débouté de l'asile en
allemagne qui souvent par l'allemand ou
par le suédois justement parce que
rentrer dans un pays ce n'est pa acc
avoir accès à l'asile oui c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé en
allemagne savent que beaucoup
d'exilés aussi à calais ont beaucoup de
familles en angleterre donc la première
chose qu'il faut faire c'est mettre
autour de la table tout d'abord les
autorités françaises les autorités
anglaises avec des avants locaux pour
pouvoir vite justement si en a beaucoup
qu'il ya des familles puissent aller en
angleterre ça c'est la première chose
l'urgence c'est la trêve hivernale on va
pas laisser les gens dehors 1 c'est pas
possible donc tout de suite de savoir
accompagner dans l'hébergement
l'ensemble d'avoir un hébergement mais
toute la structure derrière arrêtés
notamment le pillage des affaires des
temps excellent ça c'est insupportable
et c'est un dinosaure pays troisième
chose qu'il faut faire parce que ce sont
les forces troisième chose non vous
pouvez pas dire ça on a vu plein de
choses mais moi j'aimais pas pu un
moment lorsqu'il ya une expulsion
m'approcher en tant qu'élu pour pouvoir
se voir ce qu'il se passait on m'a dit
madame vous reculez donc il faut arrêter
aussi dans d'enjoliver les choses la
troisième chose c'est que moi ça me fait
beaucoup rire tous ceux qui reviennent
sur le sur les accords du touquet
monsieur bertrand etc on voit bien que
c'est la campagne électorale vous
laisser la parole mais on écoute adria 4
nages c'était ce matin qui justement
c'était sur france inter il veut revenir
sur ces accords en écoute
adria 4 nas tout de suite le député du
nord s'était un peu vite ces partis
adria 4,9
me dis que ça arrive tout de suite donc
ça va arriver tout de suite
la situation particulière de calais
c'est aussi les accords du touquet et
nous n'avons pas vocation le pas de
calais n'a pas vocation à faire gardes
frontières de la grande bretagne quand
en 2016 marque on a démantelé la jungle
de calais la grande bretagne s'était
engagé à prendre trois mille personnes
3000 réfugiés trois mille exilés en
vertu notamment du regroupement familial
aujourd'hui c'est à peine 10% qui ont
été pris en charge il faut une voie de
migration légale vers le royaume uni est
finalement mettre fin sans aucune
vengeance envers nos partenaires
britanniques mettre fin à un mauvais
accord c'est là où je suis d'accord avec
monsieur k tenace que tous ceux qui
crient contre les accords du touquet
mais les akans du touquet ont été faits
avec monsieur sarkozy donc la droite me
fait bien rire vous voyez et laden est
long il faut les garder ou dénoncer je
comprends parce que non il fallait il
faut absolument les remettre à plat et
un plan doivent plus exister il faut une
vraie une fois une voie légale et là
aussi ça va être toute la bataille que
nous allons avoir au niveau européen
sont les accords de dublin puisque
aujourd'hui les accords de dublin c'est
un réfugié qui pose le pied dans un pays
doit demander le droit d'asile mais il a
peut-être pas forcément envie de rester
en grèce engagé
britannique là dessus ce serait une
bonne opération pour la france de sortir
des accords du touquet d'après vous mais
je
crois je crains que non c'est une menace
qui est brandi très souvent qu'est-ce
qui se passerait ce serait effectivement
à exploiter par et raisonnent pas sa
peau der garde et à plus de plus de
contrôles à calais c'est le moment de
venir ou jamais
je pense que vous aurez davantage de
migrants à calais à cause de ça est ce
qui passerait comme ça en angleterre et
prenez un billet pourront faire pour
aller en angleterre pour lui prendre
bien sûr que non bien sûr que non parce
qu'il ya déjà en loin on en doute et
accueilleront les transporteurs
responsable d'amener des clones de star
en angleterre des caméras peuvent être
sanctionnés avait un amant donc de cette
loi ce soit élargie aux compagnies de
trains eurostar ou en compagnie de
ferries qui saurait y ont en quelque
sorte en privatiserait les contrôles y
aurait toujours les contrôles à calais
et or et les réseaux de passeurs qui
exploitent ce message je crains que ce
menace que c'est comme une menace
brandie l'arme nucléaire on va annoncer
mardi c'est pas quelque chose je pense
que tu vas faire très peur britannique
parce qu'ils savent très bien que dans
mon français hésiterait beaucoup à le
faire
la question qu'on pose est régulièrement
à bernard cazeneuve et je me souviens
très bien qu'il faisait exactement c'est
cette réponse l'a assuré il ya de ce
point de vue là d'un point de vue
technique je dirais une continuité
presque intergouvernementale justement
après une analyse juridique de ce que
sont les accords du touquet est ce qu'il
est ce parce que vous êtes pour bien
comprendre c'est là la frontière elle et
elle et elle et elle était à douvres à
calais c'est ça ou c'est trop binaire
c'est aujourd'hui mais c'est surtout le
fait que
s'il n'y avait pas d'accord y aurait ce
que monsieur vient de dire c'est à dire
il y aurait un afflux de personnes
encore beaucoup plus grands on ne va pas
organiser comme je le dis des ferries
pour passer en angleterre et donc ça
serait mettre en place un vaste camp de
base pour les pacers qui ferait payer
le passage est qui qui plus est
impatient
l'épaisseur c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire dans vos propos pourquoi
y at il des passeurs parce que nous
sommes incapables aujourd'hui de mettre
une politique d'accueil digne nous
aurions une véritable politique
d'accueil et c'est là où je me suis très
contente de la france parce qu'il y a
des villes et des territoires qui se
sont organisés notamment en appel salle
des territoires et des villes
accueillantes qui s'organise qui propose
des choses extraordinaires on voit que
même aujourd'hui des associations font
le travail de l'état ce qui est quand
même extraordinaire il faut leur dire
merci et moi ce soir je dois lui dire
mais j'ai une vraie pensée est pour ces
ses citoyens français qui font la grève
de la faim vous savez ils font pas la
grève de la faim pour se faire plaisir
j'écoute trois semaines qui sont en
voilà trois semaines trois semaines pour
envoyer un message très fort notre pays
oui doit appliquer des droits humains et
je veux dire que les situations
d'indignité vécu à calais ne sont pas
acceptables dans notre pays voiliers et
que maintenant il faut absolument faire
en sorte en tant que ses doigts humains
ça respecter un dernier mot natacha
bouchart je vois sur l'écran de contrôle
réagi jean je vous donne la parole pour
terminer bien que je ne peux pas pour
conclure aller dans le sens de même
karima delli cliniques qui ne comprend
rien à ce sujet et qui fait de la
politique politicienne et moi ce que je
dis c'est que il faut de la fermeté hypo
de l'humanité les calaisiens ou aussi
des droits à madame les calaisiens ont
aussi des droits les français ont aussi
des droits c'est très clairement oui
vous les avez vues dans vous avez vous
quelques vieux j'arrivais vue gelé le
vous êtes devenus potes mais moi je vous
dis très clairement il faut qu'on arrête
de faire de calais pendant les élections
comme une antienne un terrain de jeu et
je ne veux pas et je me refuserai à ce
que calais devienne un terrain de jeu
pour les uns ou les autres qui veulent
se faire une heure si beaucoup une
publicité personnelle et je resterai là
pour combattre pour défendre on a pu
population dans la fermeté à tous et
dans la dignité c'est de donner la
parole à tout le monde et je pense que
j'ai réussi peut-être un petit mot de
gars qui est intéressant c'est de voir
que on disait boris johnson et la france
mais ce dossier plus qu'un autre lui
donne l'outil d'en faire une lutte
franco-britannique parce que là on est
dans un
dossiers de relations bilatérales autant
sur la pêche il essaye d'en faire un
dossier franco britannique alors que
c'est un dossier entre l'union
européenne et la grande bretagne autant
dans ce cas là on est vraiment dans un
accord bilatéral avec les accords du
touquet et donc ça donnera lieu une
nouvelle fois à une lutte
franco-britannique dans les semaines à
venir à venir et à suivre merci beaucoup
merci encore à tous d'avoir participé à
ce débat on passe à notre reportage les
électeurs ont la parole